what's happening there reject nation we
are going to watch today from new rock
stars the batman trailer to easter eggs
and breakdown from new rock stars eric
vosso was just talking with on twitter
yesterday we are actually going to say
hi to each other tonight at the turtles
premiered i hope i'm not too starstruck
when i finally see the man in person but
it's time the time has come sorry for
not covering this yesterday um after dc
fandom john and coy can attest i was
feeling pretty sick and then uh guys
kind of got worse on sunday still sort
of recovering so i seem a little bit out
of it i apologize i can't go to this
eternal i i got to get batman off my
mind before watching the turtles so
let's watch this and then yeah let's see
how this goes
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for the batman which robert
pattinson's batman speaks well mostly
with his speech
now solving the riddler zodiac style
ciphers in the first trailer awoke
inside me an investigative obsession
that i will now focus with a frame by
frame breakdown of this trailer all the
clues you missed for this film's deeper
mystery let's get started
i've seen this trailer so many times you
guys have no idea
so many times
[Music]
we open on this rain-soaked corner in
diner where enjoying a late night latte
is paul dano as edward nashton this
movie's riddler a serial killer inspired
by the zodiac killer both the real life
figure who may or may not have been
recently identified as well as the
zodiac's depiction in david fincher's
2007 film now notice how the rain is
almost constant in this film whenever
characters are on the lower levels which
i think is another element from director
matt reeves paying homage to david
fincher but the director's detective
noir
every exterior shot in the city is
covered with a heavy rain downpour which
fincher did to underline the brutality
of urban life
it's actually making me wonder too what
the time frame of this movie will be
like because i feel like a lot of times
batman movies they might spend a decent
amount of time like several weeks to a
few months and i'm wondering if this
will kind of be a little bit more
contained in the time frame that's
actually taking place considering all
the exterior seems to be when it's
always raining or it could just be an
aesthetic choice and the other thing
that came to mind when watching this was
if you guys have played the arkham
knight video game it does start off
where they're going into a diner and
there's a cop there you actually are the
pov of the cop and it kind of makes me
flash to that too so yeah just a little
call back there now notice how you can
see a sign for the anchorage stop lower
gotham on the elevated train platform
which gives gotham a sense of layers a
division between the elite and the
underworld now actually batman's bat
cave is beneath all of this in the wayne
terminus subway line which was part of
his family's original infrastructure for
gotham that we saw in the batman earth 1
comics and apparently the subway line
has all been abandoned it could be that
the sins of his father was really to
sandwich all of the destitute of gotham
city into this surface level stuck out
in the rain with the platforms weirdly
left uncovered to expose the poor
working class to the elements because
they're on the train
why are they being covered in rain
there's really no
edward invokes another famous edward
edward hopper his famous nighthawks
painting yeah yeah i was gonna say oh
cool definitely has a little bit like
it's flickering on the window nashton
doesn't run for it and when gcpd swarms
in he calmly raises his hands to
surrender it's as if he anticipated
being caught like this the way john doe
surrendering in seven or the jokes
during the dark knight were actually
part of their master plan or loki
used to catch the big bad criminal in a
batman movie with batman not even part
of this raid meaning that either gordon
and his team were acting on information
that they did not share with batman or
batman didn't want to move on nashton
yet or couldn't yeah what it's having me
think is that nation gets caught pretty
early on in the movie like we'll see
that scene from the first trailer where
he's like duct taping that guy but then
the riddler will get caught pretty early
on but then all the crimes will still be
taking place while he's in prison so
really is having batman trying to solve
the riddler's clues while the riddler's
already in captivity
i feel like that would just be such a
fascinating movie to unfold oh yeah
watching what happens basically when the
law thinks they've got it they don't
have it then they get desperate enough
to be like you know what we got to call
in batman because yeah these crazy
serial killings keep happening oh i'm so
excited nation was drinking out of and
of course green rimmed cup green bean
favorite color and he traced in the foam
a perfect question mark it's almost out
of place how clean and crafted this is
and a movie that's otherwise total
gritty and sloppy making this a kind of
calling card from someone who wanted
this to go down this way and likely will
have several more of riddles marked
exactly this way that reveal themselves
while he is in police custody moving on
fear
is a tool
when that light hits the sky
so the titles slam in synced with the
sounds of heavy circuit breakers
flipping the third of which ignites the
bat signal with the rain hitting those
hot shutters causing steam so beautiful
like the rain trying to cool off the
hot-headed batman but failing miserably
and i love how this is not the sharply
wealthy yeah
it's like messed up
the shutters are smashed
in there and the effect is a sloppier
bat signal in the sky like a chunk has
been bitten out of the left wing kind of
like all the bruising this batman
endures as a younger brasher vigilante
use this to pull any punches and rather
than perched on the roof of police
headquarters as the bat signal usually
always is this signal is tucked in a
lower level of the building still under
construction and like everything here
exposed to the rainfall reeves call this
a year 2 batman and neither he nor jim
gordon have really risen up to their
unimpeachable statuses in gotham's
justice system yeah what i'm loving
about it being the year two batman is
cause i heard that some of the reports
were saying that he's not really
interested in being bruce wayne in this
film that he's mainly interested in just
only being batman i put out a tweet
about this yesterday i love how this
trailer is mainly just batman and very
minimal bruce wayne and i really think
that does go to enhance the mystique of
the man behind the mask where i feel
like a lot of the time in the batman
movies it's usually the character
development goes towards when he's bruce
wayne and then batman's kind of doing
his batman thing here it feels like
totally flipped nowhere it seems like
you're going to explore him as a
character as batman and not so much as
bruce i mean maybe you will but it seems
like there's so many locations in the
trailer where he's batman and not really
bruce wayne it almost looks like he's
only gonna be bruce when he absolutely
has to as a disguise or something to
further his case
it's not just a call
a warning
so we see the white face paint kids on
the train and then the shots of that
train platform from the previous trailer
meaning batman must have first spotted
these guys while they were on the train
and you can see it from the falling rain
on this side of the window and his
moving reflection oh you're right
them wow the platform yeah this is all
super voyeuristic the kids weren't doing
anything wrong on that train car they
weren't harassing that woman on her
phone and yet batman doles out total
overkill that freaks them the [ __ ] out
now notice on the wall behind these guys
is a sign with the word halloween now in
addition to earth 1 and ego jeff loeb's
batman the long halloween seems to be a
major influence on this film story as
one of the great batman detective
stories but this could also just be
telling us what time of year this is
these kids might just be a base paint
not because they're part of a gang
because they're freaking halloween yeah
i know they should be i just think it
could have been self-defense for this
creeper following them around who
thought all those joker theories thrown
out the window that was a joker gang
after average you're like oh wait it is
halloween they could just be dressed up
as this for halloween kids coming back
from apart now batman does take a shot
to the chest at point blank range
impressively deflecting off his emblem
which do look like detachable weapons
that could pop out of his chest usable
as knives or batarangs and as the shot
ricochet the guy behind him
and does a quick double take reacting to
the bullet whizzing past him and then he
freaking electrocutes the shooter in the
neck to the point where a sizzle of
smoke wafts up from his neck
a new terrifying function of batman's
gloves finger tasers moving on love it
[Music]
i've been trying to reach you
oh my god so many of us cannot figure
out what he was saying i know there's a
lot of people who are like what did he
say what have you done yeah i couldn't
make it out at first i the first time i
heard it that's why i was like oh cause
i thought he said where's harvey dead
that's why i was like oh an archery
reaction because i could have supported
what he said we were talking and no one
really knew what he said we had to play
back a few times before doing our
trailer review and i was like oh he's
just saying what have you done
it could be maybe they're multiple takes
and they left this one in a vague middle
ground to get us speculating i mean i've
seen other reactions too and other
people breaking it down where they were
saying like they couldn't make out what
he said at first either so we're i know
we're not in the dark but i i could have
sworn he said where's harvey dent the
first time i heard it
this is about a king and rivers to match
so here batman meets with edward nashton
while he is in lock-up and he wears a
straight jumpsuit labeled arkham state
hospital that was actually the name of
the hospital in joker where art
contains medical
asylum or like blackgate prison or even
the county jail suggests that nashton
might have been able to use an insanity
plea now notice that we never see paul
dano's face as edward nashton in this
trailer but we do get close with this be
spectacled reflection in the window but
he does not flinch as batman pounds the
glass you just taunt i've been trying to
reach you maybe his communication
of these additional grimes and riddles
addressed to the batman that reveal
themselves while nashton has been locked
up he pre-constructed all of this you
could actually see national paralleling
hannibal lecter in which these guys
imprisonment seems to have no effect on
their influence and in silence the
lamb's hand collector also left these
creepy little goodies ready to be found
by authorities that he just tucked away
years in advance on the outside this
riddler may also be inspired by the
riddler and batman's hush storyline in
which the riddler impressively
masterminded the whole conspiracy
against batman despite appearing to be
an already dealt with non-threat in the
plot i actually think the fact that
we're not seeing that much of edward
nashon in here is one of the most
evocative things from specifically seven
when it comes to the kevin spacey
villain character because we don't see
kevin spacey in a clear shot until the
very end of the movie but you'll like
hear his voice a few times throughout
the movie it's like even when he first
shows up at the police station at the
end you're just following behind him or
in these little shadowed perspectives
but to me that that actually feels
incredibly reminiscent of seven
specifically that one now there's an
overhead shot that shows an explosion
tear through the city alley there's
actually quite a few overhead shots in
this trailer the cinematography is also
reminiscent of zodiac one of my favorite
shots in that movie where fincher
followed the taxi in which zodiac
murdered taxi driver paul stein bruce
wayne shows up at the funeral of gotham
mayor don mitchell jr that was the
murder victim from the crime scene in
the first trailer celina kyle also
arrives wearing her tall lacy boots set
photos actually showed her on the arm of
john tuturo as carmine falcone now
remember the first clue left behind by
the riddler asked what does a liar do
when he's dead and i was able to
decipher that code using the same double
letter substitution method mentioned by
robert remember that video
to translate the creepy dad joke answer
of he lies still and i think once batman
decoded that he interpreted it as the
riddler's next target mitchell's funeral
a place where this liar politician
literally
still like
and in nashton's eyes would continue to
lie as he is eulogized as a good man and
by the way the presence of a
owl on that card combined with the
riddler's later clue of if your justice
please do not lie what is the price for
your blind eye alluding to lady justice
the symbol of the court of law could
point to the court otherwise oh that's
probably being behind definitely
on that theory in a bit let's move on i
can take care of myself
if this continues it won't be long
before you nothing less
i don't care what happens to me
it's only going to get worse for you
yeah we see some of the romantic
chemistry between selena kyle and batman
this is actually in the same spot that
gordon beams the bat signal you can see
it over there on the right and let's do
it in front of the bat signal yeah
turn it on
the wigs she wears in disguise we also
see colin farrell as oswald cobblepot
not yet the penguin and the scarring on
the right side of his face is even more
severe as if whatever slashed him across
the cheek caused the muscles beneath to
detach and droop there's also some more
recent abrasions on his head and then in
the shot of andy's circus is alfred this
guy also has a nasty looking scar across
his eyebrow is everyone in this movie
getting in bar fights yeah because it
looked like first when i saw it oh he's
kind of scarred yeah it makes sense kind
of with his own military background and
everything like that if you brighten
that shot it looks like a pretty fresh
scar so alfred's gonna get involved in
the action i mean i hope we get to see
like my favorite live action alfred
honestly i haven't seen the show
pennyworth yet but it is the version of
that alfred petty worth in the gotham
series that was on fox i love that
version and he gets his hands dirty he
gets involved in the mix i would like it
if we could see some of that applied
here to alfred who every once in a while
is not afraid to get his hands dirty
either meanwhile bruce wayne reads a
newspaper the masthead reads the gotham
times with the name mitchell across the
banner probably headline reporting mayor
mitchell's murder and then bruce lays
out all of his regular evidence across
the floor i love these kind of shots now
i would say this is just like a
brainstorming room but there is police
tape across the bottom left so this
might have been a crime scene the cops
already found but now it looks like
bruce has taken over the space carrying
spray paint so he was one to draw all of
this out i guess desperately trying to
get inside nashton's mind and it's
interesting how he is at the center
right in the question with his shirt
is really at the heart of this mystery
and he's surrounded by the hatch marks
that the riddler i guess uses in his
iconography as we see in matt reeve's
release character posters now in the
bottom left is written mitchell for
mayor don mitchell and photos i assume
from his crime scene remember on his
walls were newspaper clippings of his
recent mayoral re-election over opponent
belarus
and brain newspaper front page is
celebrating his bust of the moroni crime
family who are rivals to the falcones
making me think that carmine falcone
might have helped mitchell get reelected
it is interesting how he shows up to pay
his respects at his funeral coulson of
course refers to district attorney gil
coulson peter sarsgaard who was that guy
who was forced into plowing that suv
through mitchell's funeral and he was
strapped with an explosive collar an
iphone on his hand set to speaker mode
and no more lies taped over his mouth
and then another riddle for batman on
his chest right now that suv was marked
with the letters d-o-a which could be a
bit of a word play suggesting that the
d-a the district attorney was d-o-a-d
in the first trailer we heard nashton's
voice saying if you
are justice please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
eye
and that audio sounded chills
speakerphone echoing in that church and
i think those are the words of the
second riddle that is taped to his chest
the answer referring to lady justice who
is often depicted blind and carries the
scales and the executioner's sword to
behead the guilty so the answer going by
the setup and punchline structure of the
first riddle is probably you get a head
do you think bruce wayne is gonna go up
there be like before your head blows off
can i get that letter i solved the
riddle i think because just i need i
need just a little extra proof the thing
that says to the batman do you think it
is that's for me can i just grab that
i'm just gonna give it to batman before
your head blows up just in case it
doesn't make you get in contact with
them just please let me grab this and
now we see savage written on the floor
referring to police commissioner peter
savage played by alex ferns who i think
will be the next victim found beheaded
actually the photo to the left of the g
in savage looks like it could be a
severed head now the big clue here is
outlining a square the sins of my father
which bruce wrote here so he's referring
to his father thomas wayne i think could
be connected to what nashton told bruce
in the first trailer you're part of this
too
how am i part of it
you'll see
so what father were the quarterbacks
sins well in the bottom right there's
the phrase renewal is a lie matt reeves
has cited the movie chinatown it's an
influence and chinatown's a great movie
it's the story of how corrupt la leaders
used water infrastructure to control the
city in the 1930s and now there's a ton
of corruption and murder centered all
around that and notice how here nashton
has been targeting specifically city
leaders the mayor the d.a the police
commissioner and among those newspaper
clippings that nashton labeled lies in
the first trailer there was a sub
headline that read seawall construction
stall so i think that gotham leaders
were trying to push through a city
renewal program that involved redoing
the infrastructure of the city but
correctly doing it in a way that would
actually accommodate poor communities
and cruelty target innocent people as
criminals so they could lock them up and
steal their homes that's why i think the
wayne terminal
the wayne family originally had an
underground subway infrastructure that
could have helped the city but they
shuddered it in order to redline people
into these ghettos and now city leaders
have been leaning on their cozy
relationship with an off the books
enforcer to clear out these undesirables
an enforcer called the batman one thing
that's getting me excited about this too
is that it might be the first batman
movie i can think of that truly explores
the political themes of classes it's
always been part of batman it's always
been a part of like it's just it's just
rooted in the world of gotham it seems
like there's billionaires and just super
poor people i guess disparity you could
ever imagine there's always been that
way with gotham
but i i get the impression especially
with the kind of villain that we have
here
if all this is to be believed of what
you've been kind of hinting at that this
will be the one to truly explore it at
its most finest yeah that's kind of what
i'm picking up on which i wonder how
that will translate to all the audiences
who are just kind of showing up for bing
bang boom and rage batman yeah that's
funny to me because yeah this is the
first batman movie i can think of where
i'm like actually really excited to know
what just the the actual crime
conspiracy is that is going to be
investigated beyond just like oh what's
the riddler's plan you know like all the
cool bigger than life things is actually
getting me interested in the world of
gotham too yeah yeah cause you so often
you get caught up in like the you know
like the big mission at hand one thing i
don't really feel like the batman movies
really capture just because it's a movie
and you gotta keep it pretty streamlined
is
that if this is to be believed about how
the citizens of gotham are truly being
affected by the wealthy this will
actually make you care significantly
about batman looking after the citizens
of gotham and not just taking down the
big baddies yeah you know and i also
love the idea too that maybe the police
have been throwing things to batman that
actually are really corrupt and he might
have to confront that too it's like i
gotta be pickier when i work with the
police i mentioned court of owls i think
there is a chance this movie could
connect with the court of owls an
amazing comic story line in which bruce
wayne learns that his wayne family was
actually connected to a cult called the
court of owls who's been secretly
running gotham city from the shadows for
centuries using an executioner named
talon now batman in this movie has
similar quill line gauntlets that talon
wears i'm just thinking
police force carrying out the vision of
his cruel elitist father and now he
justifies as vengeance actually
unjustified brutality against poor
trick-or-treaters next clip
oh hey kiddies very nolan lighting there
yeah everything they say
maybe we're not so different
who are you under there yeah we see more
of this crazy violence as batman beats a
piss out of some security guards at what
i think might be cobblepot's nightclub
the iceberg lounge batman grabs the back
like a power plant
looks like an industrial factory what
even cobblepot is like hey take it easy
sweetheart he accuses him of being
exactly what the ghost stories describe
him as and it might be true on to the
next clip
inventions
here selena leaps off this ledge again
this is the same building where gordon
lit the bat signal from actually in the
lower right of frame you can see batman
wrestling with someone wearing glasses
looks like gordon ashton after his
release that looks like gordon i mean it
looks like the back of jeffrey right
hallway he just gobbles up those bullets
with the only lights coming from the
gunfire i love this it actually is
making me wonder now if catwoman is
perceived as like an actual criminal
yeah because it seems like what happens
in that police station where batman is
right it actually is making me wonder
now if catwoman is perceived as like an
actual criminal yeah because it seems
like what happens in that police station
where batman is wrestling with some of
the police officers is a turning point
in the movie like batman's been
cooperating with the police but they've
always been a little bit suspicious of
who batman is yeah and then it seems
like that's the real turning point where
like gordon will have to work with him
in true secrecy yeah and so i wonder if
like maybe catwoman is perceived as like
this terrible individual that he
shouldn't be involved with and that
creates kind of a strife between him and
gordon yeah it's like if i'm going to
break away from my corrupt police force
you got to stop working with your
criminal catholics yeah just as a little
visual reference i did find that moment
from uh planet of the apes war for the
planet specifically i put up on twitter
and yeah this whole video is just me
plugging my twitter but
all the good takes i think other people
were like yeah that's all work for the
planet of the years that's where i
specifically imagined that matt reached
pull off a batman movie too the director
of photography on this film was greg
frazier who was the same guy who shot
the movie rogue one in a number of
mandalorian episodes and with michael g
aquino's score evoking the imperial
march from star wars yeah this totally
seems like a recreation of darth vader's
blackout kill box in the quarter one of
my favorite star wars sequences at the
end of rogue one shot by the same
cinematographer and we see the batmobile
this movie an awesome looking muscle car
i love how they put the camera in these
impossible close-ups right on the
batman's hand as he cranks up the engine
like increasing the burn of a jet engine
and then somehow gets the camera right
there at his feet as he is crazy so cool
that was like a cross section of it that
didn't have the rest of the body of the
car moving on
what's black
[Music]
[Music]
okay next batman purchase on this clock
tower wearing a wingsuit glider gear
escaping the police i like how they
mount the camera on his back to show
that last cop trying to reach and grab
him as he leaps off the ledge i actually
assume this is the tower that he
ascended in the previous trailer as
police fired
so at some point with the cops turns
sour then there's this awesome looking
shot of batman caked in mud i actually
think this could be after he leads a
group with the flare into that flooded
area perhaps one of the riddler's clues
led them there that could be something
that unearths that whole infrastructure
conspiracy
then ashton's voice asks what is black
and blue and dead all over a play on the
old newspaper joke what's black and
white and red all over which nashton
literally does by painting the red word
lies over black and white newspaper in
this case the answer is you which must
be to taunt batman's bruised body as he
tried to play cop the boys in blue now
you may see this as a nod to the black
and blue nightwing dick grayson though
as this is a younger batman i don't know
if he would have had a nightwing or a
robin at this point and then we learned
that nashton live streamed some of his
riddles on social media where he wears
his military extreme cold weather mask
but wears his glasses over it just a
nice little detail similar to the zodiac
killer the way he was described by
victims as wearing a mask but wearing
glasses over the mask and then we see
batman angrily beating the [ __ ] out of
somebody if you push it on the bottom of
the frame there that is totally gnashed
in in his mask and he's hitting
themselves
[Applause]
that's not a riddle i kind of wonder if
this could be some kind of fake clue
planted to try to frame batman for all
the crimes that ridler committed this
could be what leads the cops to turn on
him moving on i'm really under the
impression that this is going to be one
of those movies where yeah it's like the
word there's the bad guy and batman
working with the gcpd has to take him
down but when the final clue is solved
there'll be this like conflicting moment
where what riddler wanted to expose as
something that has been insidious and
evil that's lurking in the shadows
batman's going to realize the riddler
was right about it the whole time not
that he like agrees like the riddler
should be set free but he's going to
realize that there was something
righteous about what the ruler was
actually doing yeah it's like his
methods of attacking it are not the
right methods but he did reveal
something very nasty under the uh you
know surface of gotham
i got you
yeah this rules i like how kabab
celebrates kind of like two-faced batman
forever when he thought that he had
burned batman alive just to have him
leap out of the flames by the way that
val kilmer batman shoot was the same one
that robert pattinson tried on for his
screen test when he was auditioning for
this role and then on to the left so is
that suit
[Music]
nice the framing of batman walking up to
cobblepot upside down like a bat hanging
in a cave the complete embodiment of
fear and on that title card that bat
emblem is laid inside the text with its
wings and hinges and segments kind of
like the bat emblem on his chest but
that central region with the pointed
ears looks less mechanical and more
hand-drawn almost like a sketch of a
child of the monster under his bed in
this film having a title like the batman
it's referring to the vigilante as a
folk legend feared by gotham's
underworld which is why i think this
batman might be more of a monstrous lie
working in the shadows of gotham more of
a villain than bruce wayne may realize
you can support new rockstars
where's your epic hero batman shirts
yeah come on
breakdowns everything you break the
internet when you put those out that was
brilliant man brilliant already super
stoked for it and yep
covered a whole lot of details i flew
over our heads guys subscribe to new
rockstars if you haven't done so already
clearly well worth it you can subscribe
to us hit that like button keep a look
out for more videos coming this week and
last but not least let's do a
everett pixelmite baker what does pixel
might mean it means that though pixels
may be small they're they're mighty it's
like the might of the the basic building
block how would ever it be pixel might
maybe ever it's like a really small guy
but for his size he's got like super
strength you know oh
you know like ants are really small but
like as compared to their body they're
like way stronger proportionally
speaking maybe that's everything yeah
we'll go with that we're going with that
you're small but mighty people are like
hey man what's your favorite patron i
mean thank you for your patreon page
what were you gonna say well i was gonna
start on a riff about how like people
are always like walking all over trying
to step over him you know trying to like
you know overlook everett out there in
the world but you know what with the
might of his pixels he's gonna be known
by everybody he's gonna tower above us
despite his stature
and all of this is ironic
yeah we don't need any of that
[Music]